the infinity war the art of the movie
art book comes out tomorrow November 6th
but of course some people have managed
to get their hands on it before and have
leaked some of the pages online this new
leaked page shows us a very different
look at the soul stone and some of its
true powers powers that we never got to
see an infinity war but could see in
Avengers for this page could also reveal
and confirm that the people who fell
victim to thanasis snap did in fact go
to Soul world I'm still doing my
giveaway giving away copies of infinity
war Deadpool 2 and ant-man and the wasp
on blu-ray as well as some special
edition posters when the art book comes
out I'll be giving away a copy of that
as well all you have to do to enter the
giveaway is subscribe to my channel like
the video and comment down below with
your thoughts and your favorite
superhero so as you can see in this
photo right here we have a picture of
fan oohs using the soul stone in battle
to push away the souls of the guardians
of the galaxy and the Avengers this is
the first time that we actually see the
Russo brothers interpretation of the
powers of the soul stone and it's the
first time that we actually get to see
Thanos use it in battle as a weapon the
soul stone got a lot of attention and
Avengers infinity war but they never
really went over what it can do
individually as an infinity stone in the
comics the soul stone allows the user to
steal control and alter souls both
living and dead and when the soul stone
collects a soul it actually traps it
inside of the soul stone itself in
another pocket dimension called soul
world so there actually hasn't been any
official confirmation from the Russo
brothers that soul world will be a
factor in Avengers 4 but after looking
at this photo of Thanos using the soul
stone as a weapon it's clear that the
Russo brothers look at the soul stone in
the MCU the same way that it is
portrayed in the comics which means soul
world will be a factor we know that the
Fallen Heroes that fell victim to
thanasis snap are coming back somehow
there's been plenty of leaks from cast
members themselves saying that they're
coming back so no questions there but
the real question is why are they now
well again this picture shows us the
true nature and powers of the soul stone
in the
Thanos is using it to control and
manipulate Souls in this photo so since
the soul stone can manipulate and
control Souls it can definitely trap
them inside of itself which means that
some type of soul world definitely
exists so that would be where the souls
of the people who fell victim to the
snap are currently at this scene would
have definitely been awesome to see in
the movie but it seems like they may
have thought that it would have been
some way of an overkill
Thanos controlling people's souls and
all that however dr. strange is not in
this photo so if they would have went
through with the scene in the movie he
would have been the one to most likely
save them but let me know your thoughts
on this photo and the true nature and
power of the soul stone and soul world
let me know your thoughts in the
comments below and don't forget to
subscribe comment and like the video so
you can enter the giveaway and stay up
to date on everything relating to
Avengers 4 as always thank you all so
much for watching
wolf wolf
[Music]